well he is known as the valley santa but
he prefers to be called
actually santa's helper every year bob
crane gives away bikes to kids in need
and as sally had amir reports tonight
this year's is actually the seventh year
he's spreading holiday cheer
but this year is so much more important
[Music]
i know it's a year everybody wants to
forget about
but i don't i've been very fortunate
this year very
fortunate and some of so many kids
been very fortunate i was able to help
them you want to go with that one
robert crane is the creator of bob's
bike for needy kids
this year he's seen so much good and
positivity come
out of the pandemic i've gotten gifts
from people
for bikes i got donations for
to buy parts i got it you know it's hard
to explain but it's
been every week something going on
crane looks forward to seeing kids smile
every christmas
and this year won't be any different
when cobra hit i shut down
just like everybody else did when they
shut everything down and then
the demand kept coming more and more
especially since it was hard for people
to find
bikes i changed my system around a lot
i've done everything by appointment only
where i wouldn't have crowds or kids and
i did everything safely as i could even
sanitizing the bikes
in march april and may crane gave away
300 bikes
this christmas 100. it just so happened
that
hit this year and it was much of a
better reason to get the kids out
and in their fresh air his biggest
reward
they don't care if it's a new looking
bike an old-looking bike or
it's a bike it's something they don't
have and
the smile just goes like that and that's
why i feel good in here
merry christmas same to you everybody
says thank you to me for what i do for
the community but
it's what the community does for me that
keeps us going
sadly 8 news now
we've been following bob for a few years
now and his goal this year is to not
have one
single bike left in his garage come
christmas day
now as for his list actually parents are
the ones who reach out to him
you can find out more information about
bob spikes on his facebook page
brian well